in this video we'll be talking about
cellular aging it's a slightly long
video if you spend your 3 minutes you
would be able to understand the overall
concept and if you spend the entire time
of this video you would have a detailed
idea about cellular aging we always
wonder why do we age and what controls
aging can aging be reversed or slowed
down these are the long-standing
question in humankind scientists are
debating among our the themselves to
understand which part or organ in our
body age at first when we talk about
aging do we know that whether our heart
Age first or our liver Age first or is
it the all cells of the body age due to
specific stress factors or environmental
factors are there genetics involved in
it all these questions would be answered
in this
video so there are several physiological
traits of cellular aging and in this
video we would try to understand how
genomic instability mitochondrial
dysfunction telome shortening and damage
epigenetic
changes disrupted proteostasis altered
cell signaling cellular
cense and lastly disregulated nutrient
sensing can affect the process of
cellular aging so all in all the these
are the clinical uh signatures or
Cardinal signatures of cellular aging
all these factors are included or
involved in the process of cellular
aging now let's talk about which genes
are actually involved in the process of
Aging the category of genes that are
involved encodes for DNA repair enzymes
they encode proteins in the insulin
signaling pathway they encode components
of the mtor signaling pathway which
regulates uh translation anabolism and
many other metabolic fact processes in
our body and also there are genes which
are associated with chromatin remodeling
enzymes so all of these G category of
genes are associated with
aging if we take the example of Progeria
which is a disease where aging is
accelerated we would see that there is a
genetic mutation in LMN a gene or lamin
a gene this particular Gene give rise to
the intermediate filament lamin a now
lamin a works like a supportive
sculpture to the nuclear envelope so
obviously when there is a mutation in
lamin a gene the product is not formed
properly and there is a breakdown of the
nuclear lamina and as a result there are
several cells of our body especially the
stem cells they die and that leads to an
accelerated aging in these individuals
similarly we can take the example of
Verner syndrome in this case the wrn
gene which encodes for a protein
involved in DNA repair and maintenance
so obviously when this particular
protein is not there DNA replication
stalls and overall repair process is
hampered in the circumstances cellular
growth and cellular division capability
is compromised that is how we understand
that genomic instability is a key driver
for cellular aging
process now the idea about aging is
actually in the genes and it turns out
Recent research found out mutation rate
actually dictates the lifespan of
individual initially the Greek
philosophers thought bigger the animal
longer it leaves for example a boohead
wh basically lives for 200 years whereas
a may fly live only one day so the size
correlates with the age but it's not
true think about a clamp that lives 500
years but it's a very small indiv small
particular organism so age doesn't
correlate with the lifespan or aging
process so what really correlates and
this recent article actually found out
an answer it turns out that there are
specific mutation rate that dictates the
lifespan for example these giraffe and
this uh mole they have basically
different in size but their mutation
rates are basically same that is why
these naked black mole and the giraffe
has comparable lifespan and this is one
of the dramatic Discovery in recent
times so now let's talk about another
important cellular driver of um aging
that is cellular cence so cence is a
state of the cell where the cell under
goes permanent growth arrest and it lose
its all capability to divide further so
cell growth and division capability is
severely compromised in this cellular
State now let's talk about Hallmarks of
cense so when we compare a normal cell
with a senent cell there are different
changes for example accumulation of
losal enzyme termed as cense Associated
beta galactosidase is very prominent
feature of senin
cells so question is what really
discriminates between these senin cells
and normal cells there are many other
criterias for example there are
morphological changes senin cells has
abnormally larged cytoplasm so they have
an increased cytoplasm to nucleus ratio
they're also flattened in appearance
another obvious marker of cense is the
lack of DNA replication also increased
level of p21 or p16 protein which
prevents cycline cdk complexes are also
a Hallmark feature of cellular cence
people think that cellular cence is a
key driver for aging process now this is
how a normal nucle look like but in this
case in a senin Cell the nucle somewhat
looks like this this is known as nuclear
cense Associated heterochromatin folky
so all the chromatin are condensed in a
different way in these
cases now recent days transcriptomic
approach and proteomic approach has
found out several drivers of cence so
let's talk about the inducers it turns
out when there is a prolonged double
strand DNA break response when there is
a tome shortening and damage when there
is enogen activation all these key
induction factors can lead to an arrest
of the cell division and this arrest of
cell division is a key feature of the
cence so the cense features include
obviously just to summarize the sense
feature include nuclear associated
heterochromatin foli cense associated
beta galact todes or sa beta gal then
there are several particular genes which
are anti-apoptotic protein such as BCL
XL bcl2 bclw all of their expression and
all of their amount is increased in the
cells abnormally also cdk Inhibitors are
upregulated in a senent Cell Ross levels
are key driver to uh to perform the
cense process and cellular
aging so now let's talk about
disregulated nutrient sensing for any
cell to grow and divide it needs
nutrient when nutrients are not a aable
cell would not divide at all it is now
found as so people have found out that
now if the if the rats or many model
organisms are fade in a restricted diet
known as alternate day feeding then
their lifespan has actually
increased and there are many research
articles which suggest calorific
restriction actually improves the health
and overall lifespan in Reas monkeys
flies or even Mouse so all these
pre-clinical studies suggest that
nutrient sensing and nutrient input
where we eat and how how do we eat the
diet composition all can actually
dictate our aging process so there are
lot of evidences from the world for
example the the S the Okinawa island
people the hunza tribe in Pakistan and
also the the another tribe in Andes all
of them has a average lifespan of
greater than 100 years but what is
common between them all of them
spiritually or ritually followed the
intermitting intermittent fasting
protocol that means they have a
restricted feeding pattern or restricted
calorie intake pattern there are many
human studies which found out
intermittent fasting is triggering
weight loss and also improving cognitive
uh uh benefits giving cognitive benefits
in patients so question is why starving
is so important because starving creates
a stress situation on the body so
obviously when you are not eating then
there are lot of so the body has energy
demand and how does body would basically
overcome that energy demand because no
nutrient is coming from outside body
would try to recycle what it has inside
already and this process is known as
autoag so in this process non-functional
proteins or organal would be uh
phagocytosed and degraded and that bits
and pieces would be used to synthesize
new proteins so let's say under the uh
condition of starvation you need a
functional enzyme so normal cases you
would make it with the amino acids but
when there is no dietary input in that
circumstances you can't have external
source of amino acids then how does
amino acid I mean how does because one
can make functional enzyme that is
required at that stressed environment
autoag is the key autoag would break
down non-functional proteins or protein
aggregates to get these building blocks
and this would further help to build new
enzymes or proteins that are required
for cellular function that is why autoag
kind of recycles all of the existing
products and that is working like an
anti-aging
mechanism and it turns out that in
Alzheimer's disease amloid PLU can also
be uh cleared out if autophagy is
induced so these are still data from
clinical pre-clinical trials so uh many
order of clinical trials are still left
so when we need a functional enzyme um
the pro the enzyme first has to be
created from the amino acids so this is
known as protein folding then eventually
the protein has to be degraded as well
now proteas mediated degradation or
autophagic degradation is pretty common
and if there is a problem in either
degradation or synthesis that might lead
to an aggregated protein so these
aggregated protein are detrimental
because they don't have they are not
functional and they also prevent
function of other proteins which are
important for any biological processes
so obviously clearing out these
aggregated proteins are important or
refolding them into native conformation
is important so this is known as proteo
stasis any problem in any of these steps
of this pathway can lead to Cellular
damage and cellular aging so that is why
disrupted proteostasis is a Hallmark of
cellular aging another Hallmark that or
another driver that lead to cellular
aging is reactive oxygen species
reactive oxygen species can can act on
proteins and lipids they can they can
oxidize lipid and lead to lipid
peroxidation which damages the membrane
ually they can also lead to damage in
the protein they can alter the protein
structure thereby altering the proteins
functionality moreover Ross can also
create double strandard DNA damage and
that lead to a overall problem in
genomic instability all this thing uh
leads to a vicious cycle that triggers
the cellular aging
process so overall in this video we
looked at the key drivers or
physiological traits that regulate
cellular aging process so I hope this
video was informative and good enough if
you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support our Channel
using super thanks see you in next
[Music]
video